[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to our
podcast and the series called High
School memories my name is suiche and
I'll be your host
today so without further Ado let's dive
into today's episode and embark on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired
today's topic will be about the benefits
of learning a second
language first and foremost learning a
second language is not just about
mastering words and phrases it's about
opening doors to new experiences and
opportunities so now let's uncover the
multitude of benefits that await those
who take the plunge into the world of
multilingualism
our first benefit is enhanced cognitive
abilities learning a second language has
been shown to boost cognitive
skills it exercises your brain improves
memory and enhances problem
solving and critical thinking
abilities it's like mental gymnastics
that keep your mind
agile benefit number two improved
communication a second language allows
you to connect with a broader range of
people transcending linguistic and
cultural
barriers is the ultimate tool of
understanding and empathizing with
individuals from different
backgrounds enhance first language
skills learning a second language can
improve your understanding of grammar
vocabulary and language
structure it depends your appreciation
for your native language and can even
help you communicate more effectivly in
your first
language benefit number three career
advancement in the globalized world we
live in bilingual individuals often have
a Competitive Edge in the job
market whether it's in business
diplomacy or the
Arts knowing a second language can open
doors to a world of professional
opportunities we have benefit number
four cultural
enement this benefit tells us that
learning a new language isn't just about
words it's about immersing yourself in a
different way of
life it allows you to expl exp
Traditions customs and perspectives that
you might otherwise never
encounter increased
creativity learning a new language can
spark creativity and Inspire different
ways of thinking as you gain exposure to
different linguistic and cultural
Concepts benefit number five personal
growth
learning a second language requires
determination patiency and
adaptability it can boost your
self-confidence and open mindness as you
overcome
listic
challenges you become more comfortable
with change and better equiped to
navigate new environments and
situations and once you've mastered one
language it becomes easier to learn
additional
ones the encourages of a li lifelong
commitment to learn a personal
growth personal fulfillment of the sense
of accomplishment that comes with
learning a second language can lead the
personal fulfillment and a deep sense of
pride in your
achievements we have benefit number six
travel
Adventures whether you're backpacking
through Europe or exploring the heart of
Asia knowing the local language can
transform your travel
experiences it helps you connect with
locals navigate more effectively and
truly immerse yourself in your
destination benefit number seven is
brain
health some studies suggested that
bilingualism M May delay cognitive
deeline and reduce the risk of neurod
degenerative
diseases it's like a mental Shield that
keeps your brain sharp throughout your
life benefit number eight academic
Excellence bilingual individuals often
perform better in academic
settings they tend to have higher task
force and can grab complex Concepts more
easily thanks to their learning language
skills benefit number nine crosscultural
friendships a second language can serve
as a bridge to forming connections with
people from diverse
backgrounds it's a powerful tool for
building meaningful
relationships can facilitate the
formation of deeper friendships and I
truly believe in this benefit because I
experience it
myself I have a lot of friends that
aren't from the same background as me so
I started to learn a new language to be
more connected with them and it really
helped the last but not least the
benefit number 10 a Global
Perspective learning a second language
allows you to see the world from a
different
Viewpoint it promotes
empathy Global
awareness and an
understanding of the
interconnectedness of our
world global
citizenship multilingual individuals
tend to have a broader perspective on a
global issues and are more likely to
engage
in international Affairs and community
service so whether you're learning a
language for professional
advancement personal growth or simply
the love of
Explorations the benefits of learning a
second language are vast and
undeniable it's a journey that not only
enriches your mind but also your soul
expanding your heart zones in ways you
never
imagined even if you're interested in
Spanish French Mandarin on or any other
languages don't hesitate to embark on
this incredible language learning
Journey the benefits are endless and
you'll gain A New Perspective that will
stay with you for a
lifetime so whether you're just starting
your language learning Journey or are
well on your way of bilingualism
remember that every word you learn and
is a step toward a more interconnected
and enriched life thank you so much for
joining us on this episode of high
school memories it's been an incredible
journey and we are so glad you came
along with a right until next you thank
you
[Music]